unfriended darkweb is the sequel to the
first film which was told entirely from
the perspective of someone's laptop a
very clever storytelling device that I
was actually very impressed with I
understand that when you sit down at a
blank page and you're trying to craft a
story the idea of creating one that
takes place entirely from that
perspective that's that's kind of clever
and very ingenious the film had a few
issues but overall I was impressed with
that movie and so I was curious to see
if they could sustain this for a second
film and this film is about someone who
has a laptop that he supposedly finds
but we later learn there's there's more
to it and the previous owner of the
laptop would really like it back because
he's involved in some very shady
dealings and so that seeps into a Skype
conversation this kid is having with
some other people his friends and now we
have a thriller horror movie told from
the perspective of a computer once again
this film for me didn't really work as
well as the first for a few things the
first film had a very tragic and rather
frightening backstory due to this
character Laura Barnes who was haunting
them for some really terrible things
they did and even though the film had
some cheesy aspects to it it felt
slightly believable I mean beyond the
ghost stuff it felt like okay I can kind
of see what they're going for and the
message they're trying to send this film
kind of ditches the supernatural element
and embraces more of a crime element and
as the plot began to unfold it required
so much suspension of disbelief that it
just kind of lost credibility for me
after a while and I started laughing
kind of unexpectedly sometimes that's
not to say that the craft here is awful
it's not to say that any of the actors
in particular are awful or the
storytelling necessarily it's just that
I know how technology works and for the
most part it feels like you're looking
at a real computer screen except the
person is like insanely fast at
everything typing clicking he never like
mistakingly opens another app or does
something by accident he rarely ever has
spelling errors and you know like he's
just perfect at everything on the
computer but
sometimes I'll look in the bottom of the
screen and when you're not supposed to
be looking at someone else's webcam like
he's sort of hid it behind other windows
I could see that their webcams were
suddenly moving at like one frame a
second for no reason and I'm like that's
an easy fix you could have done that
super easily but they left it in and
there's aspects like that in the film
that do feel a little bit lazy to me but
that's not like a film killing thing
that's kind of just like an electronic
goof that isn't really necessarily
explained they never say like why his
webcam might be glitching or anything
especially since the character's webcam
that does that is this high-tech genius
who has like servers and all types of
things behind him and you understand
that he's really good with computers
it's really just the believability of
what unfolds in regards to the villain
or villains in this film because so much
is asked of us as an audience to accept
that after a while I just couldn't
accept it anymore and the scares I found
were particularly weak there's a few
jump scares that just don't work at all
there's one character that kind of jumps
up in his seat and holds out his fists
when he hears a sound and it I can't
confirm this because I've only seen it
once and I couldn't rewind it but it
seemed like they used the exact same
image of him holding his fist when he
hears a sound twice could be wrong maybe
he perfectly mimic the exact same motion
but I would say for the first 20 minutes
or so I was actually kind of interested
there's a unique relationship in the
film the lead character is trying to
communicate with his girlfriend who
they're there at odds because she's deaf
and they have a hard time talking over
Skype and he's trying to learn American
Sign Language but he kind of sucks at it
so he tries to create an app that lets
him sign and till I show her that he's
really trying and she's not really happy
about that because it lets her
understand him but he still can't
understand her and I was like that's
actually a really good idea for a film
told entirely from the perspective of a
laptop because that would be a really
difficult thing and it's things like
that that impressed me about the film
and the writing of the film and I like
that but as soon as the whole plot
unfolds the scares basically went away
and I just stopped caring really
the the finding of this unknown folder
in his computer I thought was pretty
cool but then the ending in particular
which I won't get into it just left me
so cold and that could have been the
intent I'm assuming it was but it just
it wasn't like wow that was so intense
and I feel that it was just like oh my
god really okay well it just it just
left me kind of sad and I'm assuming
that that could have been their intent
however I did some research and found
out there are actually two endings
they pulled a clue if you've ever seen
the movie clue that film had three
endings in theaters and you saw a
different ending depending on what
theater you went to I looked up the
other ending and don't worry I won't get
into it but I definitely got the worst
ending for sure without a doubt the
other endings much better and I wish I
had seen that one but I had already kind
of checked out of the film by then and
if I had seen the better ending I'm not
sure it really would have had much of an
impact on me otherwise if you enjoyed
the first film there's something to like
here but I don't know as soon as the
plot unfolded I I just kind of couldn't
really get into it anymore I'm gonna
give unfriended darkweb a see I'm
impressed with the amount of ingenuity
it takes to tell a story from this POV
but I thought the first one was
considerably better guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]